all set
helicopters good to go thanks man he's
timely at a gathering enter and pass it
through the gates to attain to the 32
pads of wisdom but in reference to life
a little storm man you ticklish buddy
back Jesus Mac I can see their look
backs I'm doing some like really heavy
reading here and your little toy robot
is just not compatible with that type of
soldier man ok max max it's all right
pal look this just is way too
complicated for you why don't you go
play with your pig or something
see I'm trying to find the reference to
these gates here and you just would not
understand max max this is really
advanced philosophical literature here
okay you can't just start pointing this
max that's it how did you need you in
the helm wine
all right y'all we got some hell to
raise you got a boat full of moose and I
got a target [ __ ] good one - oh yeah
that's where it's at that's cool all
right okay
check it out
I sent specially a head to his hometown
of Roscoe New Mexico to prep of the
mission now there's a tunnel that's
accessible through special ease hideout
that will take you straight into the
Nazis top secret underground base where
they're experimenting with some sort of
wigged out
alien technology let's roll I'm
exclusive this was reinforced buckle me
one of yours
yeah wouldn't you like to know so you
can send coded messages back to your
pals in Berlin no what the [ __ ] is she
even doing here hey grace why she's good
people she's a [ __ ] Nazi on your boat
will be you saying huh hmm at secret
base you were talking about was
constructed by us that's usually one of
my biggest safe keeps it was located
here underground what is now Roswell New
Mexico but it existed for a thousand
years long before America got subjugated
by the Europeans
it contained technology related to
anti-gravity research something that
could easily turn the tide before we
gave the US government access to it
unfortunately was too late America fell
the Nazis took hold my safety
[ __ ] that's not going to sit well
especially he had his bed on space
aliens he wants to ship the crash back
there in 47 what do you want with this
place know what the Oberkommando is yeah
baby that's well those bigshot turks
running the Nazi war machine hangout
yeah well the Nazis moved it into your
safety set so whatever it is is so
important but the whole upper echelon of
the Nazi leadership left Berlin instead
of shot to New Mexico this is why you
need this this is a portable nuclear
bomb we're going to take out the
Oberkommando [ __ ] the Nazi leadership
and destabilize the [ __ ] country and
let the people know that the fight is
back on blaskowitz load up I'm sending
you to Roswell wizzy Roswell as out of
helicopter range so we'll drop you off
by the coast in Galveston from there you
will catch a ride to Roswell rendezvous
was super special at Papa Joe's
all-american diner and plant the nuke
inside the very heart of the over
command then he blow that [ __ ] the [ __ ]
hey guys Justin here with more gameplay
from Wolfenstein 2 with the new Colossus
in this mission BJ has to get a nuke to
area 52 in order to blow up some Nazis
to get there he has to first activate an
underground train then write it to area
52 without getting killed along the way
ammo and health are scarce and there are
some heavily armored enemies ahead
so we died a lot but don't worry we cut
all those parts out we also have
gameplay of the first mission and more
Wolfenstein coming to you so make sure
to subscribe so you don't miss a thing
you look familiar
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's house before second on speaker
[Music]
mr. German gear needed in please
gosh ma'am Willoughby was close to go
we'll be quick let's see I'll have the
last word
swishing nose you come in to attack the
Oberkommando but he has no ideas and
bring in a damn animal you got a break
in the news hello come on Peter let's go
someplace else
tomorrow's anyone oh we should yeah good
day man you one strawberry milkshake
please oh I hope you don't have a fire
back there to put out if so I'll come
back another time
I'm sure the fire can wait come and done
my job right look sick right
a man you recognize your face very Aryan
face at this - are you at a station one
there you coming up Oh
vielen dank hmm now you show me your
identification papers I love strawberry
milkshake this perhaps my favorite
American pee so simple just milk and ice
cream the rest of the menu however I
think you will need to address I think
it needs to be more German yeah tell me
are you from here John Smith huh I read
here that you operate out of station six
what is the location of station six I'm
familiar with this station
speak up come on
en from Pokemon Camelot others need
tight clean-cut nominee at bay mesh
management anonymous a commercial
[Music]
mmm
Oh bless we shut the [ __ ] front door
for anymore
[ __ ] Jim nothing ship not that I'll
trust you Blas grits there's nothing
saying you couldn't be wearing a mask
they look like William J Blass was to
hide your alien space lizard facial
traits so I mean to pass for the grace
gave you she didn't give me one
right off with a mask
show me your lizard face mother [ __ ]
super special lower your weapon for
outbreak your honor but your lights out
thank you with utair billion I just
[ __ ] with you come follow me so um
welcome to Mission Control
much what you need to clean up around
yes I'm sorry about that but um good
stuff this [ __ ] right here it keeps the
signals from getting through very
effective against alien mind reading
devices how's grace good Big Daddy
finest cream gravy I still miss her even
the pissing in the face part and maybe I
missed that the most little [ __ ]
so what he been doing down here super
special displays my papa me used this
place to collect all the evidence we
defined of the government cover-up
cookie God hasn't been more than a
decade now summer 47 I was just saying
here I quit working as a lawyer the year
I joined the black revolutionary project
after I got grace' quiz from that murder
charge the goddamn FBI pigs trumped-up
against her
maybe one night Papa heard some damn
police frequency and he brought me up
north to Murphy's ranch we found this
flying saucer life thing crashed in the
ground and what did you know it the u.s.
[ __ ] military swooped in and
quarantined off the entire Peru it was
some kind of
[ __ ] story about a water balloon
they were lying out of their asses
because we made on some actual hard
evidence there take a look at this crap
pulled that baby right out of the crash
site now does that look like something
that came off a whether own this place
so we kept records it start surveilling
with the military's up to Papa built
most of them so you reckon what you saw
was a spaceship I'm not saying it a
flying saucer from outer space but it
was clearly extraterrestrial in origin
if you catch my drift
it's all [ __ ] connected men if you
trace the chain of causation you find
yourself in a secret underground
facility about ten klicks east of
Roswell up by bottomless lakes area 52
our government captured an alien flying
saucer and they stored the salvaged
bodies and Technology in an underground
vault everyone was involved the FBI pigs
the military pigs even the goddamn King
President peg himself check this out
like area 52 area to be one over here
area 48 area 56 all over the southwest
Nevada New Mexico it's one gigantic
complex and it's connected by
underground train tunnels look at look
at pictures plasma guns mind control
anti-gravity engines and after our
coward-ass government surrender to the
[ __ ] Nazi pigs our new masters took
over all these bases and they kept doing
their own experiments do to further
their own fascist agenda look at this
this whole thing is the area 52 military
compound up here
it's the Nazi head honchos installed the
[ __ ] over commando but down here
below the cavernous vault full of all
kinds of weird-ass technology alien [ __ ]
it's all down there now I haven't seen
it myself but it's there
well whatever it is it ain't Mario
Kassar all right weak nobody knows for
sure exactly what kind of technology
we're dealing with but it's most likely
space alien based
it ain't space aliens I told myself do
you know
because are you still you some kind of
expert on all things extraterrestrial
outlook I've been a while you're a long
[ __ ] time and I know a [ __ ]
conspiracy when I see one no okay I'm
not saying it space aliens right but it
goes without saying it's [ __ ] space
aliens I got a new Monsieur fire
extinguisher okay cool it I did not mean
to rile you grace told me that you know
a way into the Oberkommando you get me
in there I will use this nuke to blow
the top brass of the Nazi leadership to
smithereens yes yes of course that
sounds so good I'm here to help
Mottola dug these tunnels to the
underground train system it connects all
the top secret military bases this
tunnel goes right to area 52 a cargo
train loading people all right now you
should put that nuke in this backpack
keep your hands-free for shooting
ah stenosis down there and other things
now I'll keep in touch on the radio help
you out
hey stay frosty blaskowitz keep going
down that tunnel and you'll end up the
areas of teaching cargo train loading
Depot fastest way to areas to to educate
you ride over those cargo trains
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
ah
I took it all
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's where their puppy copy nerve
center the open-toe is a ground level
directly above the cameras for all that
damage inside are some of their baby
[Music]
[Music]
so what the most important about
deployment it right what you gotta do is
place it in the or commandos nuclear
reactor that way the Nazis will attract
its radiation signature they will find
it the old disarm it
[Music]
what
[Music]
super special
I am armed in the warhead now you may
want to bug out of Roswell before this
thing goes boom
I have my guys across town the tornado
router evacuate the whole town the look
food execute the Halle blasts Oh
the rendezvous by Dallas done deal
designers don't want a PTO I mean others
Oberkommando spiders are faulty game
agree on FINA order and these are they
stole all day engage here
Hawaii given either this Pokemon knows
that hypothesis of the game a trio
[Music]
[Music]
another oh I envy that is over commandos
by battle there's a faulty gave agree on
I do see a puppy revisable makes is a
biomedicine there start a [ __ ] game
I'm either
oh hi gimmick Peter this former
commandos the hypothesis of 40k McCrea -
see a puppy died would make this
available Adam shift their start again
[Music]
you